l'issue de l'entretien entre sergueï
lavrov et anthony blinken est décevante
et la position américaine
inquiétante c'est la vie c'est
d'emmanuel le roy président de
l'institut et 17 17 en faveur d'une
nouvelle alliance franco russe
extrêmement déçu par le résultat que
nous avons observé c'est à dire donc un
blocage complet des négociations est
manifestement la volonté des américains
de rester sur leurs positions qui est
une position extrêmement offensive
extrêmement agressive et qui
manifestement n'a absolument pas
l'intention de reculer donc la première
impression que je tire de cette
de cette conférence de presse c'est une
bonne impression de grande inquiétude
pour la paix du monde une grande
inquiétude pour la situation dans le dos
de bath où j'ai beaucoup d'amis et où je
sais que la situation est extrêmement
difficile mais je pense que la position
des russes aujourd'hui c'est de faire
une montre de sa puissance afin de
décourager des ukrainiens de se lancer
dans un conflit qui serait suicidaire